hey yo man it's conway the machine
checking me out on the bootleg calf
podcast man you're
zelda you [ __ ] you
bullet cash show special guest in here
multiple time guests
my guy
this is the drum work podcast
essentially yeah you know conway the
machine is here what's good welcome
welcome man what's up my brother
god don't make mistakes that's right you
played me this album uh [ __ ] a year and
a half ago yeah august 2020 you know
um that's crazy to think about that
and a lot of the album is pretty much
kind of what you played me obviously
there were some surprise features
um
you got i mean we'll just we got beanie
segal on the [ __ ] project yeah yeah
which i don't think i remember hearing
the first time you played it right um
man this is the shady records
this is your shady records
commitment yes you owe them one album
it's finally coming how are you feeling
my debut baby today i mean you hate your
debut let's be honest but it's a shady
recorder's day yeah what [ __ ] he
recognizes
my first album i got interscope people
calling me about you like hey would you
be interested in interviewing conway do
you know who he is i'm like are you
[ __ ] kidding me
yeah that's fine
how you feeling though man i'm excited
for the
you know finally be able to you know
touch the streets man people can get a
chance to
you know to hear what i've been working
on over the years
i mean like i think that um
you have obviously
had the streets in your pocket all
griselda has for the last five six years
so
um
knowing that this album was your shady
records debut
you had to have had like a real vision
as to what you wanted this to sound like
because it's kind of been done for a
while yeah um you put out so many other
projects um
what was like the main goal with this
album like what was i when you were like
okay
like what what did a song have to have
for it to make this the cut for this one
um
just that pain you know i mean i feel
you know saying i wanted
you know what i mean like i just wanted
that pain on this [ __ ] you know records
like you know the cow that was from this
album
like the cow record was for god to make
mistakes um uh you know so i was always
in that bag you know i'm saying just
i just want to get [ __ ] that pain
the cow originally was meant for this
album yeah
wow
yeah that's crazy quarter that [ __ ] was
gonna be
the intro to my album
and uh
you know man uh
i don't know what the [ __ ] happened i
came
when i came back and left and when i
came back to the derringer house and you
know what i'm saying
the little [ __ ] played the
played it for weston he took it weston
threw his verse on and kept it for his
album his [ __ ] you know what i'm saying
that's why i you know i mean when i when
i make my [ __ ] with dance i keep my [ __ ]
secret like don't tell that [ __ ]
wes do what i'm doing don't play these
shits for west
you know what i'm saying right when i
heard the beat i take with without ain't
no brokeo yeah
did that happen a lot with this where
you would have you had stuff recorded
for this project and it it ended up in
other places yeah like [ __ ] uh the kyle
uh bang with eminem mm-hmm you know that
ain't that didn't make uh you know that
got leaked and [ __ ] you got a city on
the map with 50 wow that was for this
album wow
uh i want to say um i don't know if
y'all remember that mr fuji [ __ ] mm-hmm
that was for this album
may star was for a lot of um what was
she gonna do for this album wow it's
crazy because you what you could do is
you could put a record like bang as a
bonus track
you got to do the major label game now
you know kind of hack the numbers a
little bit a little bonus track action
yeah but we making so much [ __ ] though
we don't i don't be checking out that
[ __ ] man you know like when we did the
call like
you know what i'm saying i won't really
check you you got to fix the cow on dsps
though because on spotify it doesn't say
your name yeah
it's just a wes like when you when you
search up conway the cow it doesn't come
up you got to search your west side gun
yeah yeah you guys got to fix that have
empire fix it
get you have to be a primary artist on
that [ __ ] record
you know um
i'm used to not getting my flowers
are you feel like you're finally getting
them though
yeah let's see
just in general i feel like the last
couple of years you've i feel like
people have finally started to
give you the recognition as like
top
2-3 rapper on earth whenever you are in
your bag
that's still an understatement
i know how you feel two three no i know
how you feel yeah i'm just joking no no
but i know how you feel you're you're in
this [ __ ] to be
yeah acknowledge is number one yeah but
now i'm just joking around though man
but um yeah i feel like i'm starting to
starting to you know man i mean i'm
starting to see it more i would say that
i feel like it's probably you know it's
been a lot of guys especially to me the
people that matter like you know i've
been hearing [ __ ] like this from you
know early on from like
people like dj clark king
you know saying my [ __ ] raj and akane
combat jack
you know
norrie and them mm-hmm wu-tang
uh
you know royce you know ma'am signed an
eminem
uh you know it's just like people like
that like
i've been hearing
that i've been getting my flowers from
from you know from now buster
yeah when you get flowers from m m
busters
all those guys yeah so you know i'm a
hip hop [ __ ] like
like from like the 90s though like the
90s the grimy 90s era so like you know
you know i had like pro products he was
my big brother
like
all all the people like that you know i
mean that you would identify with from
that era in the grimy 90s
[ __ ] with me
wu-tang
buster
dmx i was on dmx album personally 100 so
uh
you know the locks kissing styles and
one of my brothers
you know saying like i said p was my
brother have
on my album my last album you know
method man i mean [ __ ] lemonade was a
moment math
it's kind of dope to see method lemonade
in the verses too yeah it was amazing to
see i couldn't believe he did that but
shout out to meth for that but
you know like i was saying like you know
[ __ ] like that is what mattered to me
the most so i don't really care about
you know [ __ ]
you know [ __ ] i don't care about y'all
listens and i don't care about none of
that [ __ ] i do just from a competitive
standpoint just if
because i'll just be feeling like
no that's what anybody you think
[ __ ] look at the the top 75 nba and
like man how am i
from 49 what crazy i averaged
you know what i'm saying right 25 points
with 24 people who did it i don't think
they did that did they do that [ __ ] in
order i don't know but i'm just no but i
hear you like if you're dwight howard
you're pissed off you didn't make the
list because you're like what the [ __ ]
yeah you probably i don't make you lose
no sleep right he's like i feel like i
did enough to deserve
you know the type of recognition but
at the same time i really don't give a
[ __ ] about that like because i i feel
like i'm already validated and i won
because i got people like bus and i'm
[ __ ] and ray and
royce and math and
you know what i'm saying right like they
told me i'm nice nice whole i mean
listen you got the hove record finally
which was a moment yeah i feel like last
year in general
you had so many moments on
when it came to just
whether it was dondo whether it was
working with hov
i mean just the dmx album like just some
real just iconic rap [ __ ] bucket list
[ __ ] probably last year that you could
just check off yeah like okay we got a
song with ho right yeah i mean okay yo
kanye [ __ ]
okay cool you know what i'm saying like
these are that's bucket list [ __ ]
being on a dmx's last album knowing that
you were on his album
yeah doing the bt awards
knowing dmx wanted you you know you you
could have been on like a you know a lot
of times when people pass we get an
album afterwards and sometimes the
features aren't authorized but like dmx
talked about y'all's record
you know what i'm saying so
did that feel good like last year
obviously like
you know lists aside all that [ __ ] like
just personally
on some like rap fan [ __ ] the kind of
[ __ ] you got to be a part of last year
had to be real just had to feel good man
it felt amazing i'm just so thankful and
grateful for
for everybody that you know played a
part
and and all of that like everything you
named and even the stuff you didn't name
i mean you did man you did a lot last
year one of my favorite records last
year was the wrecker dude with jid that
[ __ ] is [ __ ] crazy
yeah that [ __ ] had me on fire and then
obviously scatterbrain came but but just
in general
yeah it's just so much man i can just
you know it's just
it's just truly truly amazing man it's
dope man it's dope a lot of a lot of
moments um
let's go through some of them so talk
about the j record because obviously we
always think about right before the
pandemic hit
you performing the cow hugging hove on
the side at novo i was at the show yeah
that was that was the last show i went
to before everything shut down yeah i
think that was a lot of people's last
shows in l.a at least um it was but how
did the j record end up finally
happening you know because that's
obviously when you start running in
those circles
you know
man you know
the universe you know i'm saying this is
a [ __ ] man i just
you know one man chad like yo [ __ ] i got
a joint i need you to knock out [ __ ] is
gonna be with you
or jay and kiss
i'm like what
you feeling me like get the [ __ ] outta
here like nah for real bro
[ __ ] i did my verse at that time they
versus wasn't on it so you just got the
beat
right
my hook was on right right right right
[Music]
you know what i'm saying i'm just like
yo but i didn't even know that jade was
gonna be on it until after i did it let
me take that back like because like
i think at first they i'm thinking they
was talking like me
jay electronica and jadakiss they just
said they said jay so
[Music]
verse like wait oh getting on this too
like yeah [ __ ] i told you jay jay to
get
you jay and jayden
and jay-z [ __ ] i'm like man get the
[ __ ] out of here
you know i mean i should just like that
[ __ ] was just crazy to me
you know what i mean and then uh
man you know just shout out the whole i
don't want to say too much
you know i'm saying like you know
what was your reaction though when you
first heard the the pro like when you
first heard his verse next to your verse
on a record
like
was it did the song already come out was
it right before it came out like yeah i
hear i hear it man till it came out
honestly i didn't hear it until it was
available on dsps yeah and i was like
sharing the link in the bio and [ __ ]
like that but
man that [ __ ] just was like man
i ain't gonna lie like i had to pop a
bottle with champagne
bottle of spade like i just went i was
on celebratory time like
like what the [ __ ] bro i'm really god
damn really doing this [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying
and uh you know
we chopped you know i i you know man
me and brick bro talk all the time
before me i seen them at uh
i know y'all seen the pictures and stuff
at the
i was like the premiere or whatever like
the harder they fall premiere
and you know maybe
kind of had a little chopper a little
conversation it was just like
i couldn't believe it you know just it
just was like wow like man i wish i
could share that convo with y'all that's
for y'all though man yeah you know
that's big um
with obviously you you um being on donda
i remember when he did the second stream
and like that that song wasn't on there
i was like what the [ __ ] is going on me
too i was like no
i was like j [ __ ] ain't on the intro i
was but
did that come from i mean obviously we
talked about how you and gunn went to
wyoming uh what was that like two years
ago now right it's been a minute um
i won a couple times
a few times out there that's crazy yeah
did that record get made out there or
was this something where you had to get
out there so that was that was a record
that's been cut for a while then yeah
cut a few
cut a few that yeah i cut a few
i i think that was the only one i'm not
sure how many like wes did with him but
i'm not i caught a few out there would
he
maybe get one for the night you know
like yo what's up with that we'll see
we'll see you know
we'll see no for sure were you uh were
you able to go to
i know i saw from when i remember gunn
was on the the porch with like maryland
man that [ __ ] was yeah i missed that one
that [ __ ] was wild
i'm like the baby west side gun and
marilyn manson are just sitting there
yeah fresh off the baby being canceled
like what the [ __ ] is going this is
crazy going on i missed that one but i
went to the like the one in atlanta
so you were you had to go to atlanta did
you get to like he had like the [ __ ]
he was like living there yeah yeah
i didn't go all the way like i was
i was in new york doing some stuff so i
was able i just kind of like flew out
there for a day
and dipped like i just went out there
for like the
like the concert or whatever right
when he was out there with like the red
[ __ ] on and all that no i remember that
yeah
uh
would you say how would you say you and
kanye's relationship is at this point
cause like obviously if you've been to
wyoming a few times you got to have some
rapport with them
i like that man it's dope you know i'm
saying i think we got a you know pretty
good relationship like you know saying
if i need to you know
tap in what brothers that's
nothing to do before me and just the
love
the man's show you know saying i'm
forever grateful like when i slap on a
man wrench
you know what i'm saying i was out there
for a week or two longer than that
probably
that's crazy i've been with him and you
know saying i've been to dr dre house
[ __ ] with kanye first time what like
i'm saying [ __ ] with you how many had
dr dre is like
coming up with hooks and [ __ ] for dr dre
you know what i mean
here on release little music and [ __ ]
like he was playing he pressed play
button on
some fire like
i've heard i got a funny ass story about
that night too please tell us the story
yeah give us the dre story
not yet
yeah now i don't know that's
if it's okay
[ __ ] want that out there but man how
was drake he's crazy
drake cool ass dude man and you know
what's so cool about it
he actually remembered me and i should
like oh [ __ ] that [ __ ] remember me like
because i get there
like it's funny because
i was i was i've been on a ranch and
i've been
before i went to the ranch like
um in wyoming
yeah before i was in wyoming like
yay had a studio
uh in calabasas somewhere somewhere out
there like you know what i'm saying and
i was out there you know working on some
music and [ __ ] with him
but
in yay studios like real churchy vibes
and [ __ ] like you know i mean yeah on
his you know you're christian and stuff
so
it's not really the same type of vibes
that i may particularly be used to like
we ain't drinking and smoking in the lab
right all the homies and you know what's
that it's like
you know you got the choir in there and
like people from like church and stuff
like there so it's like it was kind of
different from me too
because i never really like
worked on like you know being i guess
like christian rap or stuff like that
like
you know my my thing is i'm grimy this
all the time you know what i'm saying
like please never pl please the sidebar
just quick don't ever put out a
christian rap album please
[Laughter]
you know say what no i'm just saying
like i never i never i never did so it
was kind of just new and stuff to me
right mm-hmm and uh so i'm out there and
i'm out there for like a week you know
what i'm saying recording going there
every day
and i just like yo man
so when we go we go one day i'm over
there um
recording long story short i'm over
there a year studio recording and we go
to you know the engineer yay wasn't
there the engineers stopped beating like
yo i just got a text yay wants us to
come over to dre's because i think you
know him and dre was working on some
stuff for the album
i'm like
you want us to
you know what i'm saying like yeah we
all going over there so we go to dre
house
and go in there and [ __ ] i'm just
sitting in there and it's like
it's mad people in a room
but like i'm seeing people smoking and
drinking and [ __ ] i'm like oh this one
that's where i needed to be that's what
i've been missing right you feel me like
[ __ ] i started rolling my backward up
mm-hmm
you know i'm saying that drake kind of
like stepped off from the board of [ __ ]
turned around you know what i'm saying
it look like oh okay yeah i remember you
because we i met him for the first time
at the uh
the star unveiling for 50 cents yeah you
guys were there right so that's when i
met him and he remembered me from that
day
and you know that's bucket list [ __ ] for
me all right just for dre to know who
you are
right just for dre to know who i am like
that [ __ ] just like different for me i
heard the speakers at his house are
crazy
this man's studios aren't real i
couldn't believe what i was seeing i
heard it's so crazy i heard like his
speech like he got the craziest speakers
nah but i've heard about it i have a lot
i know a lot of people who have been
over there and they just say oh man that
was the i couldn't believe i was there i
couldn't even believe i was there
real talk like
shout out to dre man he showed love you
know simon here
you know what i'm saying uh
with snoop oldest son
a couple of dre homies and [ __ ] like
that like it was just love like
you know we ended up working on some
stuff
actually wow you know man hopefully
we'll hear it
hope so hopefully hopefully we always
hopefully i can work on more with them
yeah like dr dre is like a
big inspiration i mean [ __ ] he just put
out a six-pack um of records last week
off of gta
which was done to work with dre
yeah now drake learn from him and just
watch him yeah his create i heard his
creative process was like very
meticulous very bro i was watching that
[ __ ] and i'm just like bro how do i get
it like his ear for like
the frequencies and yeah it's so crazy
like the [ __ ] that you see in like the
maybe in the videos and stuff where
you know i mean now that i'm shooting
videos and stuff you know how we might
like pretend
yeah you might twist the knob
he's really like like that
he really liked that
right very in the every little the
smallest detail
[Music]
that's what i hear genius it's just
amazing to watch and the studio that he
got set up is just so ill like
i couldn't believe i couldn't believe
that i was there i
wrote so i can't believe like
creative process wise
from what you witnessed from dre to
being
in multiple sessions with yay yay seems
more of like a
on the fly guy like i've seen him
recording everywhere from some crazy
studios with choirs to like a mic in a
hotel room like a lot of like uh uh the
good the the cruel summer [ __ ] was like
just in a room yeah you know
so like what what would you say like
yay's creative processes that you kind
of took from that was like a little
different ah
yeah you like that too like the same
thing i was saying about dre like
every little detail he's you know it's
very particular and very thought out
and you know he know what he want you
know the direction he won it was crazy
like i was fortunate like my first day
landing in in in out there and as soon
as i get there go to the ranch and like
he already in the studio and he got you
know we all in there
and the man made like seven beats in
front of a front of me and benny asked
benny that's crazy
like just like quick we wanted anything
like it was like we was in there all
night
it was like a couple of hours if that
like the man made seven beats fast as
hell
that's wow
like i was like when i got back to the
you know where i was staying after we
left
like and mind you we in his like in his
personal space of it like his house or
whatever this [ __ ] is
this is in wyoming yeah it's like this
[ __ ] is crazy like watching him the
whole ass ranch how he do it like he how
he like it's just dope
it's just it's just real dope man to be
able to say yo i watched
kanye create
music in the studio dr dre create
like i'm watching dre make [ __ ] a
beat in the studio it's crazy
they did that's real [ __ ] not a lot of
people on earth
what is dope to see like i feel like
quiet as cat man you're probably one of
the very few people on the planet that
can say
kanye's co-signed me i've worked with
him eminem's co-signed me yeah jay-z's
co-signed me yeah and we could go down
the list but like we're talking like
songs with everybody man it's crazy i
shoot with em hov
j
wayne hey whatever we gotta stop the
podcast real quick shout out to my
bookie man listen if you know anything
about me you know i like to gamble on
sports and i've been using my bookie for
so long go to mybookie.ag check it out
they're doing the my bookie double
deposit bonus this is how this works
you sign up you make a deposit you use
the promo code bootleg
and you're gonna get double your money
they're gonna match your deposit up to a
thousand dollars there's so much action
right now too the nba season is going
crazy maybe you could do a future right
who do you think's going to win the mvp
i don't know is it going to be honest is
it going to be devin booker is it going
to be jokic
certainly ain't going to be
[ __ ] russell westbrook
crazy odds that ain't gonna happen
that's just burning money with that
being said there's so many different
ways you can bet you could bet on your
daily games you could do the parlay i
like doing money line parlays i like to
just do three or four heavy favorites on
that nba schedule throw them all on one
ticket and and just try to hit you know
what i'm saying whatever you're into my
bookie you can bet on it anything go to
mybookie.ag they got the double deposit
bonus right now this is important sign
up for an account make a deposit and
they will match your deposit double your
money up to a thousand dollars right now
that's free money so what are you doing
use the promo code bootleg when you sign
up and you can double your money get in
on some of this nba action man it's nba
season all-star games this weekend so
much to i mean you could bet on the
three-point contest the [ __ ]
dunk contest whatever the [ __ ] is going
on who's gonna be the mvp of the
all-star game i don't know but you could
bet on it you could bet on anything so
make sure one more time that's my bookie
double your first deposit up two
thousand dollars using that promo code
bootleg place your bets what are we
doing bet on anything anytime anywhere
with my booking [ __ ] let's go
you know what song was hard that not a
lot of people are talking about is the
record on the burner album
crazy shout out wow burning man that's
my bro he put a lot of people on a song
because mozzie was on that right yeah
shout out to mozzie mozzie's on that
record
it's funny because i
like i know uh benny and mazzy were on
like a damien lillard remix together
but i always told
me benny i was like dude i just want to
hear you and mazzy like really get down
on some [ __ ] like i was like man bernard
really a r the [ __ ] out of that record
yeah burner is is too ill with it man
you know
i think you know a lot of that should
get kind of overlooked for sure because
he's so successful with
his other endeavors
yeah like his music
is hard every tape everything he dropped
man this is [ __ ] man shout out to my
bro and he be he's a good dude
he showed me there's so much love i
didn't have to i ain't going from a can
of paint
and you know saying hey rio i wanted me
got you want to get you on some [ __ ] got
me on some [ __ ] with pusher
and then next you know someone mad and
this [ __ ] and all that yeah kids and
[ __ ] play video games like that [ __ ]
just ever since then i just been like
kind of that's forever grateful
you guys are like i feel like you look
like zelda um all three y'all and burner
have a similar work ethic when it comes
to putting out music just catalog like
burn a [ __ ] around and drop four albums
in a year two of them will be collab
albums with like currency or dolph
god rest all soul you know but um i feel
like y'all have similar work ethics and
just on the independent [ __ ] like man a
lot of times it could be [ __ ] on some
lazy [ __ ] as artists and then a lot of
times too is everybody don't be having
the freedom to kind of release when they
want especially if they're on a major
yeah everybody you know it's the beauty
of being you know kind of weak when you
can do what you want
bernie can do what the [ __ ] you want to
do you drop five albums this morning if
you want
well i i was just tell we just had benny
here last week and i was like yo there's
something about uh
the fact benny signed the def jam
and then 10 o'clock four is still
independent on griselda and empire
and the fact that y'all signed this
whole shady [ __ ] deal was it
seven years ago six years ago
it's been some years
right it's been a minute and you guys
were able to
just drop whatever the [ __ ] you want
while still being on a major but still
technically being on a major
independently keep all of that and then
picking you know hey look this is the
shady album but everything else is is
separate not a lot of people got that
deal yeah i mean just you know we ain't
really trying to like sign
uh
no like regular deal like if i can't
when i'm looking at going into dells
like if i can't at least be
partners like
what are we doing right yeah i think
that um so like when i'm partners when i
have these partnerships you know what
i'm doing with my other entities [ __ ]
i'm gonna do it this over here you phone
me
see that's a drum work tape you know man
and
they work out kind of kind of good when
you just move like that like i like to
be partners
you know
on this album
some great production let's go through
who who all's got beats on the album
i got alchemists on there of course
automatic
definitely got to have my brother dan
darren's report probably produced
the most records on it
only right um
justice league i got some [ __ ] with
justice league
got some [ __ ] with uh you know cosmo
yeah cosmo beats he did a lot of burner
[ __ ] cosmos burners on the right hand
yeah they didn't album together last
year shout out cosmo that's my bro
shout out to burner for connecting that
dog cosmo's a great guy man uh
absolutely um i got bank on there shout
out bank i have uh
hit boy on there
of course um
i wanna i think that's
i think that's about it you uh
getting beanie on the project
had i mean beanie timmy is probably like
top three or four
most slept on rappers ever when we think
about just the respect of like we don't
talk about beanie like i think we should
and you know as far as being all-time
great
um i think he's in those conversations
um
uh
that was one of the features that i
didn't hear when you played me the album
so i'm assuming that was something that
probably happened in the last i don't
know what 12 months or something yeah
that happened that happened pretty
recently uh beans came to buffalo and
you know sandwiches you know beans in
buffalo yeah you're kind of buffaloing
you know kind of getting next to me and
[ __ ] and like y'all came to come [ __ ]
with you [ __ ] you know what i'm saying
like
[Music]
and we asked him some very very
very dope conversations man you know the
stuff that
you know he wanted to come to buffalo
and just
the conversations he wanted to have with
me that you know i ain't gonna talk
about right uh on camera and [ __ ] but
he's been through a lot man man yeah
just dope that he came to me
what
for
that
it's different when someone comes to you
especially in your hometown you know
what i mean yeah man
that's different you could link up with
someone in atlanta or l.a that's easy
but like someone coming to buffalo
security and none of that [ __ ] like just
on some regular [ __ ] just having this
man
how long was he in buffalo couple days
oh yeah for like a week oh [ __ ] so he
tapped in how he was cooking we knocked
a few shits out wow that's what i'm
saying like we we about to we we got
some something up our sleeve so hey wait
hold on
conway beanie project
more
border that
more than that
hmm conway on is are you bringing beanie
to drum work
well i'll see right this is this beanie
seagull on drum work
i don't know man you know i don't know
i don't know what the future but you
know we've been cooking you know what i
was saying we've been cooking i love
beanie
i would say to him
yo man
you're independent now
he really
being the goat that he is he just got to
run up his his [ __ ] now because i feel
like finally like you know he's having a
moment right now like yeah
you know i saw him in with game yeah
that song's time like
i heard some [ __ ] um
game play me i want to say game play me
a record that you were on
that's unreleased yeah yeah i did some
[ __ ] with game you know i'm saying i was
i was wondering was he keeping that or
not but listen he's got like 75 songs
yeah so yeah i did some [ __ ] with game
um
you know i'm saying shout out to homie
game man he patched in like yo bros
let's get one in let's do it you know
what i'm saying
i mean
you know i [ __ ] with everybody man like
i just like to cook yeah so just be dope
that [ __ ] that i you know i listened
to
and when i was on on the uprise of this
[ __ ]
you know wanting to collaborate with me
that should be meaning a lot so when i
will be passed down like y'all wanna get
one and i'm like [ __ ] of course when
you guys first started out
and you guys were getting some of these
features right like where there was like
busta rhymes it's like some of the early
like dope bigger features you guys were
getting
did you guys ever have to pay for any of
those features early on never
never it was always a respect thing
always it was organic especially for me
huh
i don't even want to work with you
no matter how
talented you may be and none of that
[ __ ] or how lit you is or hot you is on
radio and none of that like if it's not
organic if i never like
like we ain't never
cross paths or at least
like even on the internet way like you
know damn yeah if it's not love it gotta
just feel organic like i'm not just i
don't care about
the numbers like
perception work with nobody thinking
like oh i think i get a song with him
it's gonna i'm gonna blow right it's
gonna be a hit like i'll [ __ ] with
[ __ ] that [ __ ] with me
i [ __ ] with everybody but when kind of
being you know collabing and making
music i [ __ ] with
it gotta be organic man real [ __ ] [ __ ]
like you know what i'm saying so like
uh like france seagull this eagle [ __ ]
that's big
listen whatever y'all got coming i was
like what's the like i said i'm in a
stool box
[ __ ] i'm hugging boss like bus showing
his energy is crazy i love you king type
[ __ ]
he took me in like as a brother as a
little brother
rayquan and them [ __ ] like i've been
[ __ ] with chef like
even before he even knew i rap like i
just was around him or he met me in
buffalo and [ __ ] for the first time
saw me at a couple parties and just you
know around every time he he'd be around
me just
you know i'm on my square you feel me
i'm flying
i'm always was a flying [ __ ]
you know i'm saying having a couple
dollars and [ __ ] anyway so but i never
really brought up like yeah i rap i do
music now i'm saying
you know this was this yeah before any
of that [ __ ] right right right i was
like when you finally start hearing
people you know
like that i know
yeah
i've been around you you're rapping like
this
you know what i'm saying so
it's just everything is just all organic
early on
before a lot of them [ __ ] were suckers
man they ain't [ __ ] with us they
wasn't trying to like
collab like you know what i'm saying
they want to collab they either like
try to like
charge your [ __ ] astronomical prices
or they just like being on some suckers
you're like all right yeah let's knock
it out yeah let's lock in take my math
and then you never hear from them again
they don't reply they don't respond
a lot of [ __ ] [ __ ] like that you know
what i'm saying i feel like that's the
rap game in a nutshell what you just
said yeah it is it's a lot of people
running into each other's
and being like yo let's work that [ __ ]
still go on even in like people that's
on in the industry majors i got records
on
on my album right now god don't make
mistakes that
you know i'm saying that
i communicated we kicked the chopped it
up with the irony and we you know i'm
saying go say no names well we do the
song and then
you know they they sick the managers and
the lawyers on you and then they don't
listen you know well you know you you
got a record you didn't click yeah you
don't want to clear it you got a record
that you've played me
exactly you know the record exactly
that's that that's a real hit record
that is the problem why we probably are
never going to hear it is because of
some industry industry sucker [ __ ] and
this is a crazy record this is a record
that like to me is like
it could change your life type [ __ ] yeah
yeah it's like wild to me like when i
hear something like that and i'm like yo
how the [ __ ] is this not getting cleared
because like like
imagine if that song just never comes
out or that beat never comes out or that
hook never comes out yeah it's like what
yeah it's wow i play you know i play the
game wrong kind of you know i mean
sometimes you gotta you gotta switch up
your uh your strategies you know what
i'm saying in some situations like in
that situation i kind of like put it in
a you know
in in other people's hands to get that
get it done inside yeah taken care of
when i should have just went and just
went in the shoe box and grabbed the
money and just hanged away as mine i
already paid for it
i just get reimbursed later um
has drake ever reached out to you
obviously drake and benny got my [ __ ]
that's my [ __ ]
oh
we we we chop it up you know what i'm
saying we chopped it up and you know i
ran into him a couple times in person
and
chopped it up in the dms and [ __ ] on the
gram and all that but
we ain't never do no music and nothing
together but you know that's my [ __ ]
love like again like i'm not a [ __ ]
that like when i meet [ __ ] and i see
[ __ ] yo let's do a [ __ ] song
if it happens it happens right if it's
organic if it's organic like you said
it's all about organic [ __ ] yeah and i
you know i just feel like from the
conversations and [ __ ] and you know how
we greet each other and you know i feel
like
that's not nothing that would be
difficult to happen like if i if it just
came with two like yo let's cook one
drizzy like [ __ ] let's go yeah i was
saying i got you so less working with
wayne on this album had to be
that was one of the features that has
been on there because i had heard it a
couple you know a while ago so
obviously wayne is you know
peak wayne is
up there with like peak 50 peak snoop as
far as his most famous biggest
[ __ ] alive as far as like his
run was just
impeccable um wayne i feel like is
always super tapped in when it comes to
like
real lyrical [ __ ] even when he was in
jail like yeah he had an interview where
he said as soon as he get it get out of
jail he wanted to work with tech9 that
was like a 2010 or some [ __ ] you know
what i mean but i feel like he's always
super tapped in like how did the wayne
[ __ ] end up just happening
honestly um
uh
my [ __ ] two changed
tried to change man and i never made i
never at this point i had never even met
two chains or nothing
uh i don't even think we even did any
music together or anything
um
it's just and wayne told this story like
man you know two changes was just
hitting me it was like yo
you gotta hear this gazelle this you
gotta hear this [ __ ] conway you know
what i was saying and stuff so
and wayne was just tapped in and that's
when oh he reached out and like
immediately like yo i gotta do something
with them dudes and that's when he had
me and benny on uh on a roulette album
uh
on a funeral or whatever yeah i think it
was funny yeah i think the song was
really yeah but uh
yeah that's how that should happen
agrees how we did the joint well swap
like i got one for you he's you know i i
think i went on his podcast and mm-hmm i
remember that
like yeah you know if you need anything
man you let me know man as a matter of
fact
i got one yeah that guy got one for you
right now and he sent that [ __ ] back in
the day and then we linked up more like
it's always love like again like i said
when i see him his love we linked up
again like in his studio
miami yeah miami and
we cooked up some a bunch of [ __ ] and
like both of you guys are sports heads
too oh just watching wayne cook we got
some crazy [ __ ] we got a joint where we
going back and forth like you know
saying in and out
i'm telling you what
i'm telling you i don't know what's
going on with that giant boy you and
wayne just going back and forth going
crazy on some some some some kid style
[ __ ] yeah wow
yeah
like it's crazy because we always hear
wayne don't write [ __ ] right like it's
all shout out mac man too man mac main
is a great guy a lot of that [ __ ] for me
too that's my brother like we we talk a
lot like man mac talk all the time
that's [ __ ] crazy back and forth
yeah back and forth some crazy [ __ ] i
can't wait for it i hope this [ __ ] come
out man carter six or something this
week
cooking i'm gonna just watch them in the
cook i was in there that's the crazy
that was there i left wayne and went to
the ranch well yeah
just bucking this [ __ ] bro
[ __ ]
got some real [ __ ]
hey we gotta stop the podcast man real
quick appreciate y'all for watching uh
really mean mean it subscribe like leave
a comment even if you're one of those
[ __ ] who leaves a comment yo why
you always interrupting the guests
because it's my [ __ ] podcast i don't
know i like to talk too
anyway
hey shout out to odd socks man they've
been our sponsor from day one we go hard
for odd socks always man
literally go hard for my wife and i go
hard for odd socks
in different and same kinds of ways you
know what i'm saying sometimes i go hard
in odd socks
they do make boxers
you feel me
anyway um listen they got the ill
licenses they got the breaking bad they
got the wwe they got mountain dew they
got [ __ ] swedish fish [ __ ]
kool-aid
uh pez you know
cheech and chong what are you into the
odd socks basics are the boys though
that's my favorite you know you get
yourself a nice pair of just basics
they're comfy it's like walking on
clouds all right so you can save 20 off
if you go to oddssoxofficial.com
use the promo code bootleg kev that's
one word bootleg kev
all together
at checkout 20 off oddssoxofficial.com
go show some love and let's get back to
the interview
i would say this man like i do feel like
um
we you know we're talking about giving
flowers earlier i do feel like it has to
be said like
you are probably
the best like when we think of eras of
hip-hop
and we think of like who we grew up
listening to
and who was the best when we were
growing up whether it was nas whether it
was kiss whether it was hov
big l whatever you're that guy right now
so like our like i think in 15 years
they're gonna look back and be like man
we was do you remember the conway
griselda era yeah that's dope
that's that's man you know and i know
how important that [ __ ] is to you
because because you know i was talking
to benny and like benny's like very
kind of on the opposite end of the
spectrum because i know you give a [ __ ]
yeah as far as like you you're going for
that number one spot cause it matters to
you i bet he's kind of nonchalant about
it he's like look people are going to
give me say what they're going to say or
they're not going to say i know how
important that is to you to make sure
[ __ ] really put that [ __ ] on
your name that's cat
like i feel about this [ __ ] benny want
to be the best that's why i [ __ ]
don't sleep
and i won't [ __ ] it's just non-stop
he's not stopping and working for sure
like he all over the place everywhere
like jenny i know like you guys did this
and we talked about this in the
interview that uh him and i did that
just dropped we're [ __ ] doing some
music right now probably tana talk four
coming out i think march 11th
um you guys have a song called tyson vs
ali
um
that everyone will hear that
uh i thought an important record because
i kind of feel like when it comes to
just like the griselda fans and the
there's like a griselda reddit thread
and like
there's like you know there's just this
little world of like hardcore griselda
fans yeah and i feel like you guys kind
of like
put a lot of that like
some of the dumb narratives that people
create that is not non-existent kind of
to sleep on that record in terms of just
being like yo like
we're family at the end of the day if
you're doing good i'm doing like we're
happy for each other yeah and at the end
of the day that's really what it is you
know what i'm saying like
you know you know people
tend to love like i don't know
like a story like they love
[Music]
it's just crazy because all of our lives
and our careers has taken off and just
had a
a trajectory that we didn't even plan
out i don't think you know what i'm
saying like
benny on top of the [ __ ] world right
now you for me you're doing a million
things doing his own [ __ ]
west side same way on the top of the
world doing a million [ __ ] he over here
with it i'm doing a bunch of [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying we are just
becoming
you know we growing this is this i mean
look best case scenario this should have
been the plan the whole time right yeah
yeah
yeah
it's like like man this is
the best case scenario is what's
happening yeah man you know
absolutely
a hundred percent yeah but no that
record is crazy yeah that [ __ ]
tyson versus ali
i'm gonna say i'm gonna say you're ali
are we saying you're ali in this
in the tyson versus ali i guess so yeah
so you're ali
yeah
yeah
shout out
shout out to tana talk four though uh
man you guys are gonna have a crazy like
three or four weeks as a crew cause
between your [ __ ] and his [ __ ]
man it's gonna take over it's gonna
start feeling like 20 20 in this
[ __ ] all over again take over
time man
take over talk to me about drum work um
you know jay just play some crazy
records yeah um
crazy
i know how much of like a
hip hop historian you are yeah and i
kind of felt like last year's project
to me felt a little
kind of like jay's dynasty album in
terms of like a great way for you to
introduce
your roster
in in the form of a conway
album um
will there be like an official drum work
project coming
yeah yeah we're doing are we going we're
gonna probably i'm saying [ __ ] them up
with a compilation we got about we got a
lot of songs done we got some songs done
for that [ __ ] already
you know i just i've been having so much
[ __ ] going on right i kind of got put on
pause with
uh
you know
everything that's been happening for me
like you know what i'm saying like dmx
album
stuff
being on that and the bt awards and
the tour
happened like right after that
yeah the tour was lit now i'm in album
circuit for my [ __ ] for god don't make
mistakes and i'm going on a world tour
stuff so it's like
kind of like
are you excited for the world tour
yeah yeah i've never been overseas man
yeah it's different over there i only
been to a couple cities well since i
well now that i've been touring i've
been in a lot a lot of [ __ ] i've been to
on tour is like my first time going were
you able like like obviously was were
you ever ever able to go to canada
because i know it's tough to get into
canada if you've got certain charges you
know before you know 9 11 it was easy
you could just go over there and even
look look at your idea now they just
rory you're wondering where y'all from
usa right we are going we should we
going to the mall
switched up though now yeah now it's
it's tough yes it's tough like could you
even do shows over there
i got
shows booked over there for the tour
that's what i'm saying i got like a
whole canada like
jiffy montreal yeah
it's just a fun i'm sure there's a weird
i know certain people like that man i'd
love to go to canada i just can't they
want to be in the country type [ __ ] yeah
it's that's weird but it's definitely
strange um
when after this project comes out you
got the world tour
we know how active you are we might [ __ ]
around and get four [ __ ] albums this
year from you yeah yeah um oh it
definitely is well i would say what's
the plan the rest of the year man
yeah alchemist cooking back up again
okay and chase ski is doing a nice
little ep for the streets
i'm doing something with my [ __ ] laura
flee shout out to flea uh
stood me up when he was in l.a you're
supposed to be on the show he didn't
come uh
doing one more little installment of the
big ghost trilogy
we got to figure out who big ghost is we
do we do
big ghosts
bro yeah we gotta get we gotta get him
all the like he's just a mystery at this
point and uh i'm doing like
i'm doing some some some
business with empire too for this next
album so
all right let me ask you this like um
would there ever be a point in time
not to be in the griselda business but
were you like obviously it's always
griselda but will you like leave the
label
as far as like contractually or do you
kind of feel like you'll always kind of
be
i'm i'm contractually
done now
so any music moving forward
is gonna be drum work
yeah
yeah drum work i mean
as of right now yeah
like sitting right here right now like
my i'm not on a contract with
zelda shady none of that [ __ ] no more
i mean [ __ ] this is this the first time
in your career
it's free agency right now you heard
with that being said we all and we all
and we also need that i need that
supermax man i need they they giannis
the giannis bag
yeah and even if that doesn't happen
it's still you know grizzle is still
family gun is still family of course
that's mine that's for life i'm saying
man man being broke you know what i'm
saying i put that [ __ ] on my back man
wes took that we we've been no i mean
the the analogy you had about
doing the construction and all that is
very uh yeah yeah that's some real [ __ ]
um
are you guys trying to
you know do the you know do the
extension or you just kind of we haven't
really talked about that who knows like
i'm sure
you know i mean that's
all of our intentions yeah i'm saying in
the perfect world
right like you know what i'm saying
but i'm just saying that's right now
like it's the end like you know the
paperwork i signed was it's it's been
fulfilled it's been fulfilled as well as
with it was all in together
like my shady paperwork and zelda
paperwork
everything's
it's time to sit back at the round table
and figure out the future
what it got in store for me and you know
or just get or you know gazi will just
give you that that drum work situation
that empire and then yes
and now you are
you got your own yeah man
you can't just take the flight to san
francisco figure it out with ghazi and
nemo and hey man oh guys you're gonna
take good care of you i wanna think
about olga a hundred percent a hundred
percent damn how much of the alchemist
project do you have finished
we didn't even start yet you haven't oh
but it's in the plans to do the sequel
yeah yeah
he on tour right now
i'm doing this [ __ ] so he ain't really
had time
for us to sit down together and like
comb through some beats or like family
center batch and [ __ ] or whatever but
it's definitely coming lulu two i don't
know who my name that [ __ ] lulu too but
i think i think your new name i think
your new name yeah man i think i still
got more of that story to paint okay but
who knows it's not been named yet and
you know i'm saying but it's definitely
happening and coming out in the very
near future this year like very very
so that's the next [ __ ] i'm working on
and then hopefully we figure out what
this beanie seagull mystery [ __ ] is that
you just you just laid on us yeah i mean
you know listen man it's just something
to
start to think about for the people
watching you speculate
yeah yeah hey if uh
someone who's not affiliated with you
currently right taking out the griselda
roster the drum work roster who would be
an artist if you could pick
um and let's even take out like jay-z
and nas and little wayne all these
obvious answers who's an artist that you
could that you if you could pick to do a
whole album with you know what i'm
saying that you think could just hang
with you with the bars that you think
would just be dope
like with some underground [ __ ]
semi main street you know but like
obviously you could be like i want to do
an album with drake or jay-z and that's
like low-hanging fruit like give me give
me a name
signed out to be fire who what like who
i would love though yeah just who you
think would be hard who who you think
the fans would appreciate too
that's a great question uh
ah wow that's a great question man
oh
that's a great [ __ ] question man
i don't know i really don't know who i
could think you know what i'm saying
like probably like
who would i want to do or take with like
that'd be crazy
i have no idea bro
something that might be random
maybe russ
kiss or styles would be hard
yeah
um
low-key lemonade was such a moment you
and method man
all that well six-piece with meth might
be crazy that would be insane hmm
me and mad me and russ
me and lox
yeah probably
probably me i'm mad how about this you
and mozzie
a [ __ ] with mazia that would be crazy i
feel like on the block just on talking
about the pain and the relatability and
the bars
mozzie
and congrats to mozzie who just signed
with cmg congrats geez yeah that's fine
i saw that he got a nice situation too
so shout out to mazzy
sweet situation
um all right so this album man it's out
uh bubble for [ __ ] this probably will
come out right before the album drops
out the 25th
the 25th 25th don't make mistakes
how much input did m have
on this project if any no
none you just send in the album this is
it him and you know
what about feedback wise did does he
give you feedback yeah yeah but it was
uh
i'm gonna keep it on it i uh i went to
detroit
and i was in you know in the studio and
paul royce
and played him album front to back and
he [ __ ] with every record i was like
this [ __ ] this is ready to go
and that's when like he he jumped on
bang and
50 got on the city on the map joined
like that
even though we lost those records but
that's what i'm saying i i played on the
tape
it was like i didn't have no it wasn't
that was the critique like yo this [ __ ]
is [ __ ] amazing this is ready this is
ready yeah
do you even like
have anyone who's critique you like or
like like who even has the power to tell
you like yeah this one ain't gonna take
it off like or do you give do you give a
[ __ ] like if whether it's gun or m or
somebody
everybody if i respect them when they
like appear on my craft you know what
i'm saying they give you input you're
open to that right you know if i'm a
pilot and i fly
planes for a living like
somebody that just took a flight here
and there can't tell me how i should
have landed the flight you know what i'm
saying but like
it's just another pilot that flies too
and been flying longer than me or
whatever like
i'll take i i ain't one of those type of
dudes i'm open at criticism you know so
yeah like with skis was to be like yeah
no i think you could have said that last
line a little harder
little ella that you could have ended
that better i could have
you know we we've done that yes and
benny when we cook and stuff together
you know
maybe tell each other like nah bro say
that low
say that last part a little better
you know what i'm saying oh i i i you
talking about that last night all right
i got you
yeah i said was that a west side
impersonation okay
tell me
i love this impersonation
oh you go a little crazier yeah
hey um were you at the uh chiefs game
the one i mean the one no
i didn't go to that one you know what i
was saving my energy for the super bowl
i ain't going to that because
the bengals had already handled a
business
so i knew once we beat the chiefs we had
us another home game and a playoff super
bowl and then the super bowl so i'm like
i will go to that game yeah when that
confetti falls so i can you know get on
the parade flow like kevin hart and all
that [ __ ] you very what unfortunately
you know what i'm saying how was you
know i can't imagine the emotional
rollercoaster that that game was to be a
bills fan because that [ __ ] as a as just
a football fan
i was on the f that was probably the
best game i've ever watched ever watched
like i think texas versus usc when it
was vince young and matt leinart was one
of them you know what i'm saying but nfl
wise i can't think of a better game
man
perfect quarterbacks perfect ratings pl
both have perfect games like weeks in a
row for patrick bonds two weeks in a row
perfect games
but jot man it was uh i mean if you're
not patrick for josh for josh yeah for
sure uh but
for me
personally that kind of stung worse than
us losing them super bowls man
yeah because you were probably a lot
younger at the time i was gutted i ain't
gonna lie like you know when
you know watch josh marches down here
scored a two-point conversion
39-36 we you know 13 seconds left
the coach and josh they hugging and it's
just i'm in my house i remember what
like
me and everybody in my house just
running back and forth
going crazy
and too much time i know it was i know
we was in trouble when they kicked the
touch back and they didn't just like let
some of it let some of the clock run
yeah i'm like do the squid kick right
i'm like you take three four seconds off
that clock it matters
easily so i'm like wait a minute
and then i saw the defense like the
whole middle of the field and they got
timeouts left i'm like
scratching my head and then that first
first down i'm like
this [ __ ] ain't over
and
at least y'all got josh allen for the
rest of the [ __ ] for the rest of his
career he ain't going nowhere yeah man
we y'all got one yeah we got one man i
think josh got has to be of course
outside of like the bradys and the
errands
i think i i will take josh allen before
any of them [ __ ]
i might agree with you
give me josh allen cause you know what
you got you got the threat of that run
yeah
you got the hurt he's like who i wish
kyler murray like he's like who i think
kyla murray actually is but josh allen
is really him yeah because kyla murray
is five feet tall jackson i love you
know saint patrick
mahomes i love
burrow patrick mahomes [ __ ] family
annoys me i can't deal with it what's
the homie out here
stafford just oh herbert's a beast i
love her what everybody is they already
i'm taking josh it's my turn to pick
and i know what i know by watching the
film like
what i've seen so far in their careers
give me josh
that's 65 260 270 whatever he is running
and throwing like the rocket arm
with that hurt that dog getting like
that
give me that one that's some real [ __ ]
hey you're
i think why people love you so much man
is cause you are extremely transparent
you're extremely honest you're extremely
vulnerable when you rap
um
and when it comes to just like everyday
[ __ ] that everyone deals with that most
rappers are too cool to even talk about
whether it's being depressed sometimes
whether it's being down just down and
out you know what i mean that [ __ ] is
something that i think
a big reason why a lot of people relate
to your [ __ ]
um for people who are going through some
[ __ ] because it happens normal people a
lot of your fans go through [ __ ] man
like
when you're in those spaces mentally
like what is some advice you could give
to to people to try to get through it
man because i know you've been in some
dark places
uh
you know talk to somebody you know what
i'm saying like you know
it's just it's it's it's better to talk
to somebody you know was saying i
i was one type of people that kind of
like just keep [ __ ] bottled in
kind of you know compartmentalize and
keep that [ __ ] like
i'm good you know i'm saying yo [ __ ]
what's good bro you good like yeah i'm
good you know what i'm saying
it's like it's better to just have you
somebody that's you you [ __ ] with
whether it's like your girl or your
you know your mom your uncle one of your
homeboys or
somebody that you know you trust you
trust
that you know that give a [ __ ] about you
unconditionally like
you know i'm saying i got love for you
regardless of what you're going through
i'm gonna be here to support whatever
decision
and you know as long as it ain't like
bad you know negative [ __ ] but like i'm
here for you
you got that you know we all got that
one person that you know we always can
get count on and give us the ear
and we i feel like you know
talk to that person hit that person up
and just talk you know what i'm saying
like
i felt so much relief
when i
talked to somebody for some reason
and my whole life i was just was the
total opposite like i don't i i bottle
up
i don't talk i just like
and then just like it's investors
good it's like that ain't good you start
dealing with it in bad ways you know
what i'm saying
like now i have people you know i'm
saying i have people like
that i could you know just like even
today you know i'm saying i'm gonna give
you example i don't keep it a buck like
i was kind of like
frustrated and [ __ ] about some [ __ ] that
kind of
[ __ ] with me and took me out of my
zone like you know me all my good energy
my good space
and i'm like [ __ ] everything i ain't
doing medicine i'm right here i'm booked
my flight i'm going home i ain't doing
none of the interviews none of that [ __ ]
is over [ __ ] that you know i just got
into you know my old so i just
caught myself and i just like
wrote me up one and i called that person
who i was just talking about that you
gotta have
i called that person who's that for me
and just
talked to them about like yeah
she gonna be mad as hell though man i'm
tired of that
like no you need to do
you know what i'm saying and you go from
there you don't have to out just do what
you know you make your own decision at
least you have
someone that i'm just going to give you
what i think
now you listen or you you do it or
whatever that's on you but i don't think
you should do that right that's that's
not good like it's important to have
that person when you're doing all this
or not like you you send yourself back
you know what i'm saying
that's important yo me and you are both
degenerate sports gamblers um sports
gambling is so much fun i love it but i
also hate it in the street like that
i hate it but i love it
you've posted some amazing tickets
you've had some [ __ ] hits especially
when you started you were hitting some
of those alternate lines where you were
between 13 and 17 [ __ ] like that he was
on a run
but we don't see the losses
i had a really bad year last year
bounced back finally
take me through the worst time as a
sports gambler you've been through like
just whether it was just because when
you take a big loss there is no feeling
like that in the world it sucks it's yes
i go like the only thing that's worse
than if i like bet big
and i lose is if
like for example
recently this [ __ ] happened i lost
literally by like a half a point like
that's the worst
like was it a parlay yeah uh
it was like a it was like a six-pick
parlay
double digit thousands of dollars
and
[ __ ]
for me it was mike white from the
[ __ ] jets it was uh
it was uh that [ __ ] me too oh my god
it was the bucks i had giannis
players special
44 and a half he had 44 in the third
quarter was that rebounds and points
winning by 30 right and it was winning
by 30. so he took him and played the
whole fourth quarter just needed a half
a [ __ ]
one get a rebound get something i was i
was like yo
that's the worst
you're like yo hopefully this team goes
on a run and they got to put them back
in i've been there i've been there i had
a
the bills go to the super bowl i put a
ticket in eight grand would pay me 72
000.
i did it at the beginning of the season
and that was close because if y'all
would have got through that game no way
the bengals are surviving i don't think
hey man what
bangers would look like kittens if
someone had to give you
let's say you had to put you hey
you had to throw 10 grand down on a
future for the nba championship
who's making the finals
right now right now
i'm gonna say uh
i gotta give it to you okay oh my god i
gotta say phoenix
i wanna say golden state man they they
yeah i haven't seen
finals yet but you know [ __ ]
could get warm every that's my mom i
think i think i think clay's not the
same guy defensively anymore which i
think is a problem right i think that's
the problem is defensively clay's not
who he was three years ago so right
who's gonna guard devon booker and chris
paul in the western conference finals
it's it's not gonna be clay and steph
wiggins no they're gonna throw gary
payton in there yeah but yeah then you
got then you leave mikhail bridges open
in the corner jay crowder
johnson
thank you all right what about the east
what about the east i gotta go to
brooklyn
so you like the trade
i love the train i think brooklyn should
[ __ ] around and try to get the seven
seed or eight seed so they have more
games kyrie can play in in the playoffs
because if they got home court advantage
he can only play
in
a certain he can only play in three of
the games if it's a game seven game
series because if they play at home he
can't play
you'd almost rather go play
away the whole [ __ ] playoffs so kyrie
can play well as long as we got old
number seven man
we are katie's a killer yeah we fine
did you see that uh did you see the
draft with him in lebron
the all-star draft i didn't watch it
bro they lebron purposely they purposely
left hardin out there this is the day of
the trade yeah
purposely did no one took hearted and
charles barkley and shaq are roasting
the [ __ ] the whole time
katie's just sitting there with a
straight face annoyed as [ __ ]
and it comes down to rudy goldberg james
harden
and and charles barkley's like let me
guess kd you need some size right now
i gotta check that yeah it's crazy well
listen the album man go run that [ __ ] up
it's gonna be a big year for drum work
gonna be a big year for you yeah thank
you man um looking forward to
what everything you got going on man
yeah thank you do you have uh i know the
weed [ __ ] are you still doing the weed
[ __ ] yeah i'm still [ __ ] a little
weird you still got the strain yeah
is that i mean because now now the new
york shit's legal so yeah yeah it's kind
of you know i got more in store for that
you know it's uh
i got a lot of [ __ ] going on for this
for this next you know year
and the merch is always booming yeah
merch going crazy the merch is going do
you have a special drop coming
for the album yes yeah i got some
sneakers on the way i got sneakers yeah
i got some some some air force one's
gonna work just hoodies i got some teas
i got [ __ ] going on man custom air
forces yeah i got some [ __ ] going on
okay well there it is man the machine
going on the machine baby how many how
many times have we done this we've done
this a lot now exactly man we finally so
hey i will say this i was in buffalo and
i actually got to go
we went went to the east side of buffalo
went to the street you grew up on yeah
yeah
your family's house
uh
across the street was where the house
used to be that you used to trap out of
but it was an empty field i think now
yeah
man i would just say this man the
hospitality you showed me out there was
amazing no question and um
i never i would say this i've never seen
i've been to everywhere right i've been
to atlanta i've been to florida been
everywhere i've never seen
somebody really run their city
like y'all got buffalo yeah wherever we
went we saw
the hoodies the hats the chains the
billboards
like everywhere everywhere you look it's
you benny your gun in some capacity
and it's truly like a wild thing man and
anybody who's never been to buffalo
yo go jet just go check go check go tap
off
just don't go to the new era store
thinking there's gonna be some heat
because that [ __ ] was weak i think that
should close down thank god we were so
excited when we found out new era
started in buffalo and our hotel was
across the street from the store
we walked in that [ __ ] like we about to
come up on some heat yeah that shows me
it was not it anyway conway the machine
boom